americans facing some very tough choices
as the coronavirus
surges just before the thanksgiving
holiday it's next thursday
officials in 28 states have tightened
restrictions over the last two weeks
and during that period the u.s has
recorded more than 100 000 new cases a
day
for 14 days in a row those numbers are
much higher than they were
early in the pandemic omar villafranca
is in el paso texas where a
stay-at-home order is already in effect
omar how are the city's hospitals
handling the spike
well good morning we're here at the
medical center and there are more than
one thousand coveted patients in el paso
hospitals right now for perspective
only 25 states have those kind of
numbers now the county judge here is
working with businesses on new health
restrictions
as leaders across the country are
working on new measures to slow the
spread of the virus
across the country a return of scenes
from the earliest days of the pandemic
long lines for testing from los angeles
to miami
in chicago grocery store shelves were
emptied of essentials like toilet paper
and cleaning supplies on monday
after the city's stay home advisory went
into effect
and each day a parade of state and local
leaders announcing new coronavirus
restrictions
this is simply the fastest increase
california has seen
california governor gavin newsom
announced monday he was pulling an
emergency break on california's
reopening
halting most indoor activities in 41 of
the state's 58 counties
in iowa the strain on state hospitals
led governor kim reynolds to announce
a new mask mandate in nearly all indoor
spaces
and a ban on indoor gatherings of more
than 15 people
after months of resisting calls to do so
if iowans don't buy into this we lose
and our health care system will fail
and the cost in human life will be high
and after new coronavirus cases jumped
700 percent in two months philadelphia
officials announced a six-week ban
on indoor dining gyms and museums across
the city
consequences to health and not doing it
are really bad
it's just been so overwhelming the virus
continues to rip families apart
bonnie surya nahara of el paso lost six
family members to covet 19
including both her parents not even an
hour had passed when they tell me
your mother just passed away when i get
a call and say we're about to put your
dad on a ventilator
nahara also lost an uncle two aunts and
a cousin
she says watching her mother celebrate
her final birthday a year ago
is bittersweet i love seeing the videos
because i love seeing her face
it makes me so mad that i'm never
gonna have the opportunity that our kids
that our family is never gonna have the
opportunity
to have another birthday celebration
there are some disturbing numbers out
from the american academy of pediatrics
they say more than one million u.s
children have tested positive to date
that's one in every 11 cases since the
start of the pandemic and something else
to consider
students are going to be coming home for
the upcoming holiday season and the cdc
says
while younger people and children tend
to recover faster
they can also spread the disease much
quicker
tony it's definitely a concern omar
thank you very much